it will not surprise you guys that over
on CNN they had documentarian Ken Burns
on with John Berman and of course
they're comparing desantis's move to yes
you guessed it the Holocaust we woke up
to the news this morning that Governor
Ron DeSantis of Florida sent two plane
loads of migrants to Martha's Vineyard
off the coast of Massachusetts including
kids and whatnot and I'm not saying this
is not a one for one this is not a
parallel here in any way but it does
address some of the same themes that are
part of this documentary The abstraction
of human life it's basically saying that
you can use a human life that is as
valuable as yours or mine or Limbs and
to put it in a position of becoming a
political Pawn in somebody's
authoritarian game this is the coming
straight out of the authoritarian
Playbook this is what's so disturbing
about DeSantis is to use human beings to
weaponize human beings for a political
purpose it's like when somebody
disagrees with him in Florida like the
Walt Disney Company he punishes them
I mean there's so much stupidity there
just real quick I tweeted out two images
and as you can see that Auschwitz and
Martha's Vineyard are a little bit a
little bit different than each other uh
Viva
is this a bit much I mean there's just
no there's no there's no bottom to the
hole right there's no but can you
imagine in the same sentence where he
says it's inhumane to exploit humans for
political pawns let me pivot into
selling my documentary by the way I it's
it's Shameless and it's first of all I
don't even care about their hyperbolic
idiotic comparisons period but they talk
about exploiting humans to sell their
books to sell their documentaries
there's no connection whatsoever and
it's almost as bad as Chuck Todd
comparing 9 11 to January 6. also
speaking of not using people as
political tools but January Sixers are
as bad as the terrorists that flew
planes into the World Trade Center I
mean it they're incorrigible because
they're not honest in what they're doing
they are there to mislead the question
is how do you reach their base
I think it's happening in real time you
can feel the seismic shift in the social
media Universe uh and the more that they
compare this taking migrants and
bringing them anywhere in America I mean
they got to go somewhere so Martha's
Vineyard it's comparable to the
Holocaust but leave them in Border towns
leave them in detention facilities On
the Border towns that's fine because
Martha's Vineyard doesn't have to see
them then build some detention centers
in Martha's Vineyard let people see what
actually happens in reality maybe
they'll start changing National policy